unexplained illnesses irreversible
trauma and possible encounters with the
Paranormal horror Stars should be
convincing on screen but how far is too
far
it's hard enough to deal with the
fundamental fear and discomfort that
comes with filming a horror movie but
it's something else entirely to get so
physically impacted that you end up in a
hospital that's what happened to Joey
King on The Conjuring set and the cause
is still a mystery king recalled the
scary experience during an interview
with people in 2022 saying it was pretty
intense some weird things happened on
the sets along with the movie being
scary it's true I developed this bizarre
rare out of nowhere blood disorder and
basically all the red platelets from my
body were like drained they were just
gone this experience was more than just
an unexplained bruise or cut that could
have occurred from a physical scene
King's condition was life-threatening as
doctors feared that she could have
internal bleeding the diagnosis required
daily trips to the hospital both before
and after filming however when she
returned home from the shoot there was
no sign of the illness Patrick Wilson
told the independent that King had even
more strange occurrences on set noting
that children's scenes don't require
stuns but that she ended up with bruises
that looked remarkably close to the ones
King's on-screen mom has in the movie
whilst and kept silent on the issue at
the time so as not to scare his 12 year
old co-star
the fifth installment to The Conjuring
franchise the nun UPS the chilling
religious iconography to 11 and creates
a truly terrifying backdrop for a slate
of Haunting encounters as much as the
movie made fans spines tingle actors
taisa Farmiga and Demian bachir were
right there with them except they had to
live through it getting buried alive is
a major fear for a lot of people and
bachir had to live out that horror
repeatedly while filming the nun during
an interview with Yahoo movies UK the
non-director Corin Hardy didn't hold
back when it came to pachir's coffin
scene he noted that bachir hated the
confined space but he commended the
actor for his willingness to continue to
re-enter the coffin as filming required
if those screams seemed a little too
realistic though now you know why
told comicbook.com about the experience
saying it's not fun to fall into a
coffin and be there I'm comfortable with
small spaces but that's not a good thing
I'll try that at home kids meanwhile
Farmiga had her own fright within close
spaces the actor recalled that during
one scene she had to hang out in a dark
closet until cameras started rolling her
isolation from the rest of the crew made
her uncomfortable so she had to request
some company to stay calm during the
shoot she said I was terrified because
for a good probably a minute minute and
a half I'm alone it's pitch black I'm
waiting for them to call Action I asked
for them to send someone to sit with me
because I was a little too scared
there's just something about The
Conjuring franchise it opens up its
actors to a world of real-life
paranormal scares more often than not
horror films feature child actors which
constantly leads to a whole new
generation of mildly traumatized horror
movie alums Mckenna Grace was only 13
when she filmed Annabelle comes home
which is considerably younger than the
franchise's Target demographic of
R-rated moviegoers despite that Grace
was fine with most of her scary scenes
it wasn't until the horrors seeped into
reality that it really left a mark
literally during an interview with the
rap Grace recalled a particularly
disturbing moment during filming she
explained when all of us were on sat
together for the first time the lights
went out and we were all freaking out
and asking Annabelle are you there then
the lights turned back on and my nose
was bleeding so heavily strangely enough
the issue went away immediately after
she left the room between malfunctioning
lights creepy shadows and a broken
Rosary Grace's weird experiences would
be enough to traumatize an adult let
alone a young team to make matters worse
every time Grace tried to take photos of
the Annabelle doll it came out black
most fans didn't quite know what to
expect when they walked into the theater
to watch Barbarian and were left shocked
by what they saw fans weren't alone in
being surprised by the film however
actor Justin long was right there with
them in fact long was so wigged out by
the script that he needed to take breaks
from reading it at points unfortunately
he wasn't exactly in a reassuring
environment at the time it's typically
not a great idea to consume horror media
let alone the script for barbarian when
you're hanging out in an RV in the
middle of nowhere
and according to an interview with the
AV club long had to learn that lesson
the hard way he told the outlet that he
actually read the script while staying
in a Louisiana RV park a setting that
made him extremely uncomfortable
although long admitted to being afraid
of the dark the cocktail of reading a
terrifying script in such an isolated
and exposed environment would be enough
to freak anyone out some of the most
captivating and creepy moments of horror
come from the unknown barbarians
certainly hones in on that concept and
it sounds like Long's outdoorsy digs
felt just as bizarre as the movie's
Airbnb
plenty of horror actors experience
Trauma from the intensity of their roles
and the less an ideal physical and
mental conditions are subjected to yet
sometimes a movie can be so rough that
it causes PTSD hereditary actor Alex
Wolff told bias that his role in the
movie made him feel so horrible it
caused him memory loss he explained it's
hard to describe eloquently it's just a
feeling I don't think you can go through
something like this and not have some
sort of PTSD afterwards
you don't feel that
I feel what like you don't feel the air
flexing Wolff told the outlet that he
subjected himself to some pretty intense
emotional turmoil to get into the right
headspace to play the traumatized
teenager however it wasn't until he
started unpacking that experience that
he realized he'd blocked out parts of
the trying process he recalled to Vice
when I started talking about it all
these splashes with all this disturbing
[__] I went through sort of came back
and flood he kept me up at night to
where I got into the habit of emotional
masochism at that point of just trying
to take in every negative feeling I
could draw from Wolf's experience is yet
another example of an actor diving so
deep into their role that it irrevocably
changes them in many ways it's a strong
indicator that Hollywood needs an
overhaul of how films and TV shows
handle these roles
not that acting might wield some
incredible performances but it can also
be pretty dangerous for the actors both
physically and mentally fully immersing
oneself in a character can result in
some pretty dire consequences
particularly in the horror genre for
example Florence Pugh's performance in
mid-summer is incredible but it came at
a cost some actors stand by the
intensity of their method acting and the
results it produces but Pew expressed
some regret over her acting choices the
actor spoke to the off menu podcast
about the intensity of a role saying I
would just be Imagining the worst things
because each day the content would be
getting more weird and harder to do on
the subject of her characters trauma a
Pew explained that she deliberately
tried to put herself in miserable
situations to try to ascertain a
sensation of grief she admitted that she
even felt actively guilty about the
experiences both her and her character
had to undergo to make the film few
added I was putting things in my head
that were just getting worse and more
Bleak I think by the end I had probably
most definitely abused my own self in
order to get that performance there's no
denying that Pugh's controversial
approach to her character created a
powerful performance but no role is
worth such a dangerous degree of
personal immersion
sadly not all actors make it through
their traumatic horror experiences the
1994 film The Crow fits into multiple
genres but it certainly has horror
undertones Brandon Lee starred in the
cult classic but sadly never got to see
the film's success as he died due to an
accidental gunshot during the final
weeks of filming a piece of a dummy
round had been caught in the barrel of
the prop gun Michael Massey's character
fired on leaves the fragment acted like
a bullet when the blank was fired Lee's
death is a sobering reminder of what can
happen when a film doesn't employ proper
safety protocols Massey was so
distraught over Lee's death that he quit
acting for a year and he told extra in
2005 that the accident forever changed
his approach to filmmaking since then I
am very conscious
of the dangers of making a movie and and
it is a dangerous proposition in the
same interview he said that he wanted to
make sure a mishap like that never
happens again and that he relied on the
support of his family and friends to
slowly work through the trauma caused by
the event while his career went on to
include memorable roles and numerous
films and TV shows after his death in
2016. many of Massey's obituaries
prominently focused on his tragic
association with the crow and Brandon
Lee
not all weird horror movie stories occur
on set when it comes to the Paranormal
all bets are off especially when the
film in question is fictionalizing real
folklore when Patricia Velasquez scored
a lead role in the curse of La Llorona
an offshoot to The Conjuring franchise
she opted to take the method approach to
get into character unfortunately this
strategy came with some creepy
consequences the tale of La Llorona was
all too familiar to the actor who grew
up at the threat of the spirit looming
over children who behaved poorly well
you see they call it a legend a folktale
but for us Latinos it's a she's a she's
real it seems that filming a movie about
the spirit reignited her childhood fear
Alaska has told Refinery 29 that she
often sensed someone being on set
Velasquez shared a pre-filming prayer
ritual that she does before bed to get
into her character's heads in which she
asks her inner self to reveal that
character's struggle after she went to
sleep one night Velasquez heard what she
described as a mashup between a scream
and a howl and a cry her daughter heard
the disturbance as well and in
Velasquez's haste to get to her
daughter's room she sustained into
injury the actor is convinced that she
had a run-in with the real La Llorona
and that the fear she felt for her
daughter helped her connect with the
entity and her character Velasquez
recalled it was so scary but at the same
time I was like oh I get it now I
understand her pain and I understand her
desperation
Annabelle strikes again the doll is
amassed quite a few names on the list of
actors she's traumatized but it's not
just the kids who aren't all right it's
fascinating that though the Annabelle
doll Bears no resemblance to the actual
doll she's based on she still inspires
fear and is often associated with weird
inexplicable activity in the Annabelle
origin story Annabelle creation actor
Miranda Otto wanted absolutely no part
in dealing with the doll she told
cinemovie that the doll's presence was
so palpable and creepy that she has to
do rehearsals without it in the room
whether you call it brilliant prop
design work or something more Sinister
or Annabelle has a way of getting under
people's skin while Anthony lapalia
wasn't necessarily freaked out by the
doll she still got her claws into him in
another way he explained the cinemovie
for me it depended on the light and
certain light it looked pretty benign to
me then I'd walk in and it would be a
different light and different shadow on
the face and suddenly the eyes would be
on fire some of the film's younger stars
were also put off by the doll Lulu
Wilson was on the same page as La palia
regarding Annabelle's eyes and talitha
bait man wasn't particularly fond of
Annabelle's dilapidated form
[Music]